well i'm all embarrassed now
uh what do i say after that thank you
thomas it's a really um
overwhelming introduction and i just
hope that i i live up to it
first of all i'd like to to thank the
good people here
in the burns library and the irish
institute and boston college
as they know full well i have a special
uh place
in my affections for this college for
for reasons
uh which everyone associated with the
college knows about
and i'd like to thank uh both tom hatchy
and bob o'neil for
once again um opening their arms with
very splendid hospitality to
welcome me here once more i do have one
once small problem though which uh you
might be able to help me
help me with uh it relates to the fact
that yesterday i was in a place called
south
south bend indiana at a university
called notre dame
where um i gave a a talk to a similar
group
the irish society there and i was driven
down to
uh south bend uh by a very nice uh man
bill young who filled me in
on all the do's and the don'ts and one
of the don'ts that he told me not to
by any stretch of the imagination do was
to mention to them that i was going the
next day to boston college
and each time i asked the people in not
today
why shouldn't i tell you i'm going to
boston college they shrugged their
shoulders and said gee i don't know
so maybe you can tell me later
if i can just explain why um
i embarked upon this project it's it was
a four-year
research project and writing project it
took a great deal out of uh
out of my life um but i decided that it
was very important to
try to discover what had gone on inside
the ira
during this extraordinary event which we
call the peace process
you know we know so much about some of
the players
bill clinton's role and john major's
role in albert reynolds role
and uh george mitchell's role and we
know what happened to the good friday
agreement we know what david trimble
said to
so and so and so and so but what we
didn't really know
we we had a version but what we didn't
really know was what actually took place
in the most important organization
involved in the peace process and that
was the ira
which unprecedentedly has brought its
campaign of violence to an end in
circumstances which i think most people
here would agree who followed
the story in northern ireland they would
have thought to be uh
completely uh beyond imagination at 10
15 or 20 years ago and we've ended up
with a peace process
which i believe is despite its problems
fairly stable and solid but we did have
this
this difficulty of knowing or trying to
find out what was
uh what was going on in the ira during
this particular point in time i
covered them as tom said for best part
of 20 years
and i found the whole process
extraordinarily puzzling because i knew
what the sentiment at grassroots level
was and i knew what the leadership was
doing and there seemed to be a huge gap
between the two which never
came to anything but it was a very
difficult process to understand from
that point of view so i set out to try
to discover
uh what did happen and the the product
of that endeavor is this book which i
hope
i hope you will enjoy as we sit here
tonight in boston
and look across the atlantic at
unfolding events in ireland
it's easy to think that the good friday
agreement and the peace process are
facing a possible terminal
crisis with well-founded allegations of
ira spying
and other activities such as the
adventure in colombia
casting doubt on the genuineness of the
ira leadership
the institutions have been suspended by
the two governments by the british and
irish governments amid demands that if
they are ever to be revived
then the ira must disband or give
another
equally convincing signal that its war
is indeed over
this is i say is an understandable view
of events
but it is i believe a deeply flawed one
the process
has survived every single crisis it has
faced so far
not just because it has weathered these
crisis do i say it's going to survive
this one
in fact i will go further and say that
northern ireland is pop
very possibly now entering the final
phase of the peace process
one which will see the end to the ira as
a revolutionary violent
and destabilizing force in irish
politics very possibly by disbandment
but just as likely by some other means
such as a very public
videoed perhaps act of decommissioning
together with a statement of intent
and that i believe would uh have the
potential to bring a comprehensive
comprehensive end
not just to the troubles which have
lasted as you know since the mid 60s or
1969 70 depending on your view
but also to the ancient anglo-irish
conflict as well it's a truly historic
event
the pessimistic view of what is
happening in ireland is wrong
because it ignores two key features of
the process
one is the electoral gains north and
south of the border made by sinn fein
that's the iras political wing gains
that have put
jerry adams party on the verge of
overtaking the moderate constitutional
nationalist party the sdlp
once led by john hume now led by mark
durkin as the largest nationalist party
in the north
and which have made shin fein a growing
political force in dole erin
so much so that it is not inconceivable
that in one or maybe two elections
time one could see sinn fein forming a
junior partner
uh in a coalition government with let's
say finna fall uh
and what that would mean would that is
that sinn fein would be
in power exercising governmental office
in both jurisdictions which would be
quite an extraordinary event
both these advances and the
transformation in jerry adams image
from the days when he was depicted
regularly in the british and
occasionally in the american media
as a ruthless marxist terrorist what he
is seen as now a peace making pragmatic
statement
statesman whose links to the ira are
very tenuous and who is welcomed in
at least the clinton white house if not
the bush white house have happened
entirely because of the peace process
without it none of this would have been
possible
so to condemn the peace process to
failure at this stage would be
from feign's point of view to imperil
all these gains
an act of lunacy i argue and that is why
the party keenus to get fresh political
talks going the party that is pressing
hardest
for the restoration of the good friday
agreement is shin fein as those who are
following events back home
will be aware and it is why at the end
of the day
tony blair bertie ahern and george bush
for he is involved as well
will get their way and the ira will
begin the slow process of dismantling
its structures
that's one reason why the pessimists
have got it wrong
the other is that jerry adams has been
working very hard
for a very long time often in great
sequence
secrecy with considerable ruthlessness
and resolution
and at no small danger to himself to
steer maneuver
and even manipulate the ira ira away
from armed struggle and into
constitutional parliamentary politics
to call what he has done machiavellian
would be to seriously understate that
achievement
and that's in a country where the
adjective machiavellian has been applied
as you know to
uh politicians as famous as collins and
de valera
and as tricky and wily as collins and
devalera
the notion then that he and the small
group of confidants that he has gathered
around him
would at this late stage of the game be
content to see the situation slip back
into violence is so absurd
as not merit the moment's consideration
for a long time the three gov
the three governments that is the irish
british and american administrations
together with jerry adams and the
leadership
of sinn fein as well as some enlightened
unionists not all of them but some
have shared a common view of the
northern ireland problem it hasn't
always been obvious
the ira's continued activity for example
the spine that i talked about earlier
the colombian adventure and so on
which and i argue incidentally that the
colombian adventure and
other activities which the ira has been
caught with its hand literally in the
cookie jar
should really be seen as part of adam's
management of his hard men rather than a
sign of preparing
uh to return to war all these things
obscured this basic reality
very soon however i believe the clouds
and the fog will roll away
and we will see it all so much more
clearly the story of how jerry adams
maneuvered the ira into constitutional
politics pushed them down a road they
normally would have avoided and rejected
is the story of the book that have been
asked to talk to you about tonight the
secret history of the ira
some have argued that the book is really
about adams but i would contend that
such has been
adam's influence in and on the ira that
the two are inseparable
so who is jerry adams and what were the
influences upon him that were to lead to
the peace process
he was born into a west belfast ira
family in 1948
in a northern ireland where the lot of
catholics especially working class ones
like his family
and this extended family more
importantly was decidedly second class
a quarter of a century before in the
wake of the anglo-irish war of 1919 1921
the island of ireland had been
partitioned into two states
one now called the republic was free to
secure
a growing independence from britain
which it has done the other northern
ireland was still
constitutionally tied to britain thanks
to the wishes of its majority
the one million or so protestants
descendants of english and scottish
planters who had been resettled from
tudor and stewart times onward
to secure england's interests on the
island and to act as a buffer against
catholic european invaders using ireland
as a backdoor into england
and of course they had used either force
or the threat of force
to exert their will on many occasions
the island had been partitioned as i say
for
the best part of a quarter of a century
when jerry adams was born but there was
division among irish nationalists about
what to do about it moderate
constitutional politicians argued that
reunification and independence in
ireland could only come about
when the northern unionists agreed the
notion that you could bomb
a million protestants into united island
was both immoral
but more importantly also impractical it
just wouldn't work
violence they insisted was not the way
to persuade unionists and they put
forward the so-called consent principle
as the only way in which this goal could
be achieved that is that irish unity
could only come about with the consent
of the majority of the population
in northern ireland against them
arranged the small band of republicans
the ira
who had refused to accept the
partitioner settlement of 1921.
they argued that in 1919 and again two
years later
the only times in recent history when
they had voted as a single unit
the irish people had overwhelmingly
chosen an irish republic as their
favorite option
partition then from this ira ira dentist
point of view was a rejection of the
will of the irish people
a rejection of the principle of national
self-determination
it had been forced upon ireland at the
point of a gun and they believed it
could only be removed by the gun
the ira's raison d'etre then was its
opposition
to the notion that unionists had the
right to opt out of the opt-out of the
greater irish state
that was one fault line within
nationalism the other was what to do
to change northern ireland itself
catholics who made up a third of the
population had been discriminated
against from the very start
they've been discriminated against in
terms of access to jobs to skilled jobs
in particular
to housing and and also to voting rights
and we know the stories of
gerrymandering we know the stories of
some people having three votes other
people having no votes
they've been discriminated from the very
start in the north island state and this
was the way in which unionists
believed that they could maintain their
control over that society
but every nationalist whether they were
moderate or extremist no matter what
their views were about
uh the consent principle or uh
revolution agreed that this should end
the question was how moderates argued
for reform within northern ireland
they said nationalists should recognize
the state at the beginning of the state
the nationalist party had boycotted the
the parliament in belfast
they now argued that the nationalist
party should join it and become the
official opposition
and participate in the other
institutions of government just like a
normal
parliamentary democracy while at the
same time demanding equality in housing
jobs and so on
and so forth on the other hand the
traditional republican view
said that only the destruction of
northern ireland of the northern ireland
state could achieve the removal of these
inequalities
the state from their point of view from
the ira's point of view was
fundamentally irreformable
so there were these two divisions within
nationalism consent versus coercion
and reform versus revolution and what
makes the peace process so significant
and so historic
is that jerry adams has brought the
largest the most extreme and the most
violent brand of republicans seen in
ireland
i would argue this century the
provisional ira to accept both consent
and reform as their guiding principles
and to reject coercion and revolution
and that is why i would argue that this
settlement has the potential to end the
entire conflict the anglo-irish conflict
and not just these troubles
when jerry adams joined the ira as a
young teenager
at 16 or 17 in the mid-1960s the
republican movement itself mirrored
these divisions
the dublin leadership under its chief of
staff catholic golding
assisted and advised by various marxist
academics wanted to take the path of
reform and to put away the gun
they advocated recognizing the two
parliaments the one in dublin
and the one in belfast these were the
two parliaments that traditionally the
ira
uh loathed and hated and rejected and
they backed a program of left-wing
agitation politics and wanted
republicans to stand for election
uh in both jurisdictions in dublin and
in belfast that effectively meant
recognizing the 1921 settlement
conservative ira men uh particularly
those in the rural areas
opposed all of this seeing it as a
betrayal of all of those who had given
their lives for the republic of 1916.
matters came to a head in the summer of
1969
a civil rights campaign backed by
moderates and hardline republicans alike
again they made common cause on this
had convulsed northern ireland the
simple demands for one man one vote one
man one job
uh or one family one house uh rocked the
northern ireland state to its very
foundations and unions weren't unable to
deal with it
some fundamentalist unionists led by
people like ian paisley and bill craig
and others
opposed the civil rights movement
violently and that august
august 1969 loyalist mobs searched
surged
through catholic belfast burning homes
and shooting people
they met virtually no resistance at all
and that was because the ira had largely
disarmed on the urging of the cattle
golding leadership in dublin
and the northern catholics traditional
defenders had been made toothless
the result of that was a split a
division in the ira and that happened
within months
over the new year of 1969 1970 the
impetus for the new breakaway group came
from the north
where the issue that radicalized people
was not political ideology but the need
to defend their own
streets from attack from protestants and
loyalists southern conservatives in the
ira who were motivated by ideology found
common cause
with northern dissidence on the issue of
defense and the product was this
umbrella under which they could all
shelter
which became known as the provisional
ira but the important point here i would
argue is that defenderism
not the republicanism of wolf tone the
fenians of the 19th century
or the men of 1916 and the dublin rising
was the real inspiration for the provost
and that had to shape and develop
their politics including the peace
process
jerry adams's sympathies were divided on
all of this he supported the dublin
leadership's left wing and agitation
policies and sympathized with the idea
of entering the parliaments
but he had doubts about the ability of
the unionist to peacefully accept reform
as the events of 1969 had showed after
sitting on the fence for a few months
and then seeing many of his
contemporaries
and all but one member of his family
side with the new ira adams joined the
provisionals
it wasn't long before adams influence
was felt in the new belfast brigade of
the provisional ira
while most of the new group's leaders
were older veterans people like joe
cattle
seamus toomey jimmy steele people who
had been active in the 20s 30s and 40s
who had spent maybe half their lives in
jail
they were the official leaders of the
new provision ira but adams was one of
the few representatives of this new
younger generation and there weren't
many of them in 1969 1970
but he was also talented and very bright
he'd gone to
what we call in northern ireland a
grammar school that is a school
in which uh pupils are selected
essentially to end up with a college
education
he left school before he was able to
finish and qualify but there's no doubt
that he was
intellectually capable of of doing that
the violence of 1969 obliged the british
to send troops to the
to northern ireland and under unionist
control and direction it wasn't long
before the troops clashed with catholics
with whom at the very start they had
been friendly
because they had been seen as a rescuing
force had come to protect them from the
loyalists
unlike the ira but as this violence grew
and its ranks swelled the ira moved away
from defense to offense
taking the british on taking the police
on attacking bombing shooting
adams quickly made his mark first as a
commander in his own bailly murphy area
a sprawling housing project a huge
housing project
very poor working class housing project
in west belfast
and then through various promotions he
made his way to the top becoming belfast
commander
his ira career in these days was marked
by two qualities and i'll
mention just toot as illustration one
was
his radicalization of his own housing
project in valley murphy
as i say a housing project of maybe five
to ten thousand people in those days
it shared a street with a local loyalist
area
and for reasons best known to themselves
and most people suspect because of
pressure from the unionist government
the british army forced through an
orange march into bali murphy and the
result
was a vicious rioting which lasted for
several days
the ira brigade leadership decide this
is under billy mckee decided that they
would teach the british a lesson and he
sent him a squad of armed men to take on
the british in a gun battle
when adams found out he was outraged he
put them under house arrest
and his his rationale was very simple he
wanted
his people in valley murphy to be
radicalized by street
conflict uh combat fist to fist
stone to stone conflict with the british
army and the riots that followed lasted
for the best part of a year
the ira did not fire a shot in valley
murphy during that time
the result was that the valley murphy
project produced
uh the most tenacious and largest
section of the ira in belfast a factor
which contributed no small measure
to jerry adams own influence in the ira
as a whole
it's very ruthless strategy because it
resulted in an awful lot of people being
injured
people joining the ira who otherwise
wouldn't and as a result of joining the
ira going out to kill people
and don't underestimate incidentally the
effect that killing people has
on organizations and people who are
members of the ira
so many people that i know who who have
been in the ira and who have killed
are shambling alcoholics now as a result
of what they did
um others were killed others went to
jail
um the the consequences as a for
for that community of that tactic uh
were quite considerable
the second example uh of his
considerable strategic skills was his
pioneering excuse me pioneering of the
use of the car bomb in belfast now the
car
bomb contrary to all the various
theories that were put forward about its
invention was discovered
by accident the irase quartermaster
general in dublin a man called jack
mccabe was experimenting with homemade
explosive mix
in his garage outside dublin and
foolishly he was using a metal spade
in his garage to do so there was a spark
and the whole lot went up he was so
badly burned he died
but there was an awful lot of this mix
left over and people didn't know what to
do with and someone had the idea of
sticking it into a car driving it
into the center of belfast putting a
fuse attaching a fuse to it
and seeing what happened and of course
the result was this massive explosion
and jerry adams was the first one to
realize boy this was one hell of a
weapon and from there on
the use of the car bomb became
characteristic of the belfast
ira particularly his battalion the
second battalion in
in in the valley murphy and lower falls
lower falls area now he used that tactic
to force the british to introduce
internment without trial in august 1971
prematurely the british
don't forget had uh had come over 69
1970
the troubles really got underway
mid-1970 towards the end of 1970
even by mid 1971 the the british
intelligence on the ira was
was it was insignificant they really
didn't know their way around they didn't
know
uh who was who in the ira to give you an
example of the ignorance and uh
naivety of the day when the first
british troops
patrolled uh streets in in west belfast
on the falls road in these big saracens
which were called pigs
um they would stick pictures of the
virgin mary on the front in the hope
that this would protect the
the saracens from being attacked by
stone throwers they were that they were
that naive so
this was the time we were talking about
he used the car bomb to blast the heart
out of belfast and
to to attack other commercial uh targets
uh in the in in the rest of the city in
such a way
that the pressure uh from the unionist
government
uh led by brian faulkner to introduce
some sort of security measure
internment was was was irresistible and
so the british army moved perhaps six
months nine months earlier than they
should have
and they arrested the wrong people they
rested old men dogs
children people who had been veterans 30
40 years before they didn't get any of
the senior people
or any of the activists in the current
ira and indeed i think only one
member of the ira in belfast was
arrested in that swoop and that was
jerry adams's cousin kevin hanaway
the vast bulk of the ira escaped but the
effect of internment was to radicalize
the entire catholic population the sdlp
the middle class
catholics led by
very respectable people protested
that this was a one-sided move it was a
counterproductive move and they withdrew
uh from the the institutions of northern
ireland and
uh thanks to jerry adams skill uh thanks
to his use of the car bomb
again a very ruthless uh instrument uh
the situation had been transformed
in an extraordinary fashion not least in
the way that the iras ranks
after august 1971 were swelled by people
joining up to try to strike back to
hitback people
even returning as far as as far as far
from as far as
united states and canada indeed the
longest-serving
ira chief of staff
was inspired by the august 1971
uh internment operation to to return to
to belfast to return to tyrone and
set up an ira unit there without it he
wouldn't have taken that action
so a very very important event
so he was ruthless and skilled in that
way
he was also ruthless in other ways under
his direction
the ira in belfast began the practice of
disappearing its embarrassing secrets
chilean style
informers whose activities if they
became public knowledge would make
the organization appear vulnerable or
its leaders appear to have been
weak or or to have made mistakes on one
celebrated occasion
a low-level informer a widow with 10
children by the name of gene mcconville
was disappeared simply because public
knowledge of her death would make for
bad headlines
and it wasn't until bill clinton
involved himself in the peace process in
1996 that
first of all the ira admitted that it
had disappeared people like gene
mcconville
and that they maybe had disappeared
during this time when adams
along with other people was leading the
belfast brigade perhaps 10 to 15 people
and the campaign was started to recover
their bodies unfortunately and alas
only one or two of their bodies have
been recovered june mcconnell's is not
one of them
these were bad days though everyone was
ruthless
gene mcconville was killed by a ruthless
belfast brigade staff
but she was also being used and employed
by a ruthless british army who knew full
well that she had been twice warned
by the ira that if she was caught in
forming again she would die but they
continued to use her
so hard up for intelligence were they
these were bad days and the ruthlessness
was everywhere but that was the way
people
advanced in those days particularly in
the ira
by the late 1970s adams had made it to
the national leadership of the ira to a
seat on its ruling
seven-person actually seven-man army
council there's never been a woman
on the army council and for a brief time
in the late 1970s he held the post of
chief of staff
and i would argue that the qualities of
ruthlessness and strategic dexterity
that characterized his time as a rising
ira star
were also the qualities which he was to
bring to bear upon his colleagues
when the time came in 1982 1983 to
commence the enterprise which the world
would eventually know
as the peace process
so why did jerry adams go down this road
um perhaps only his wife knows his
confessor and his god knows
but i can speculate on one or two
reasons one possible reason
was that it was clear by the mid-1970s
that the ira was incapable of defeating
the british militarily
that the prospect of bringing them to
the negotiating table and forcing them
to negotiate terms for withdrawal
had essentially gone briefly in 1972
there had been a moment when that was
possible
but it very quickly disappeared and i
suspect that by the time jerry adams was
imprisoned in 1973 he'd come to realize
that the ira had lost the military
initiative and was essentially on the
defensive
while it couldn't be defeated nor could
it win
and i believe the other reason was that
he had not lost the preference for
politics which he had shown
before the ira split in 1969 and i
believe that this is where his heart
always really and truly lay
and when ira hunger strikers began to
win seats to the british and irish
parliaments in 1981
the moment had come to commence divorce
proceedings
which would ultimately and eventually
separate armed struggle from politics
it is surely no accident that the moment
the peace process can be said to have
been born was just a few hours
after shin fein had for the first time
under its own name
won seats to a parliamentary body in
ireland hunger strikers had won seats
owen karen
uh had succeeded bobby sands but again
as a as a hunger striker candidate shin
fein for the first
first time had stood as a party and had
won seats
uh delivering a shock uh political shock
to
to uh to opinion in ireland which i
think took them an awful long time to
recover from
and they won four seats um sorry five
seats
uh to that particular experimental
parliament adams was elected in west
belfast martin mcguinness
in derry and three others elected in in
other rural nationalist constituencies
and that was in october
1982. coincidentally just within hours
of the results uh being declared the ira
in south armor kidnapped a local
protestant member
of a unit of the british army militia
known as the ulster defence regiment
and everyone when they heard that news
knew exactly what was going to happen
that this poor man was after being
interrogated
by the south armor ira a prospect which
would be enough i think in most cases to
cause a heart attack he was going to die
a pretty terrible death and that there
would be reprisals that the loyalists
would
also know what was going to happen to
this poor
poor soul and that they would uh go out
and take their revenge on innocent
catholics and that of course
unfortunately is exactly what did happen
but fearing these terrible reprisals a
priest called father alec reed
from the redemptorist monastery in west
belfast in clonard
which overshadows the area tremendous
emotional social economic and even
political influence on the people of
that area including jerry adams
and his own family father alec reed
called on adams knowing full well that
adams was a member of the ira
army council and uh would have been in a
position to intervene asked him to plead
uh asked him to intervene for the man's
life now according to the accounts that
i was able to uh
to unearth adams did make attempts to
try to
get this man released but it was
difficult apparently to get messages
down to south ammar
it's too late to stop the south amer and
the man did die a terrible death
and what he went through the agonies
that he went through before he did dai
can only be imagined
and there were awful reprisals in
belfast the uvf killed a catholic
and kidnapped a catholic and killed him
in just the most grotesque and brutal
circumstances
so it was a terrible time but from that
contact between father reed
who had been in belfast since the 1960s
and whose piecework
had been well known but who had suffered
an enormous breakdown during the ira
hunger strikes and was now
only returning to to peace work from
that contact came conversations between
him
and jerry adams which later embraced the
leadership of the catholic church in
ireland cardinal thomas sophie
and also uh the vatican principally
through a senior vatican official who is
now the archbishop of saint louis justin
regali
kept the the pope the present pope
informed of what was going on
and their aim was to design an
alternative strategy for republicans one
that would be non-violent
that started circa 82 83
those discussions of which we only have
the briefest glimpse
and i don't claim in my book that i have
the the complete story
um but we do have more of a story than
we had before
the full story is bound to be a
fascinating one and hopefully one day
the documents will will be released
this was nevertheless a dangerous path
for adams to take
discussions like these were bound to
involve compromise the catholic church
would not have gotten involved in
discussions with jerry adams about
a political alternative to violence
unless they were aware
or had reason to believe that he was
prepared to compromise on those two
issues that i talked about earlier
the principle of consent and the
abandonment of violence and revolution
they wouldn't have done it otherwise
so these discussions were bound to
involve compromise
and accordingly if they'd been known by
adam's colleagues on the army council
they would have been opposed by them
probably with violence and it's not
stretching the balance of imagination to
say that
uh the consequences for adam because
atoms could have been extremely severe
although i suspected status would have
saved him from the ultimate penalty
and that would have been the opinion
elsewhere in the ira at this time
and so for the next decade or so adams
conducted the peace process
in conjunction with advisers from the
church
in conjunction with a small group of
trusted confidants in the belfast ira
a group of people who are called inside
the organization
the think tank out of the side of the
rest of the ira and with
the assistance of these very small
numbers of people uh the peace process
was pushed on
the conventional view of the peace
process up until the publication of this
book
is that sometime in the late 1980s and
early 1990s the sdlp leader john hume
sat down with jerry adams and basically
talked some sense into his head
and while john hume's contribution to
the peace process was extraordinarily
significant
he did for example he gave it two
qualities he gave it a respectability
and acceptability that otherwise it
would not have have
would not have had you have to remember
at this time
the people who were involved on the
irish side in the peace process aside
from jerry adams
were cardinal ophe who had been
described by a unionist like ian paisley
as an ira cardinal from crossman glenn
southam
and the other person who was involved on
the irish side was charles hockey a man
who'd been accused by unionists and
british and
a lot of the irish media as being the
man who would actually inspired and
created the provisional ira back in 1969
so if these talks have been discovered
um
the consequences for all these people
would have been very very severe indeed
but
hume's involvement given that hume had
the status that he had particularly in
the south
amongst constitutional nationalists gave
it a respectability that otherwise
wouldn't have
and secondly he did on a number of key
occasions much later on
saved save the process when it was about
uh to collapse
but nevertheless the evidence assembled
in this book
i think shows clearly that the
initiative for the process began
with with jerry adams and father reed
much earlier than anyone had imagined
and much earlier than john hume's
involvement
and that it was they who propelled it
along the road
it was also part of the conventional
wisdom that the british did not get
involved in the peace process until the
1990s when the british secret service
mi6
opened up conversations with martin
mcguinness
who had two roles in the ira one was his
northern commander
of the ira in other words he ran the war
on a day-to-day basis
in northern ireland and he was also
chairman of of the
uh ira army council and in that capacity
was if you like the ira's diplomat
senior diplomat it was he
who acted as their ambassador you wanted
to go and talk to the ira
about this that on the other you went
through martin mcginnis
so the the conventional wisdom as i say
was that
that contact started sometime in the in
the early 1990s between mi6
and martin mcginnis and that's when it
started but again evidence published in
this book
shows i think fairly comprehensively uh
via
on the record confirmation from two
former secretaries of state tom king
peter brooke
as well as various documents that adams
was in contact via the redoubtable
father reed who i have to say
whose role in this whole peace process
while it is known about
uh is not as widely or as greatly
recognized as perhaps it should be
but anyway the adams was in contact with
the thatcher government as early as 1986
and that by the next year he had in his
possession
from the british government a message a
secret message
uh outlining the basis outlining what i
called the root map
for for the peace process this is a
crucially important document
and i reproduce it in full in the book
and it makes the fascinating reading
for it sets out the root map as i say
for the peace process and subsequent
events show that it was largely an
accurate map that the hills and the
contours of the peace process
were more or less mirrored in this
document and there were a number of key
points in this proposal firstly shin
fame would have to accept the principle
of consent
the idea that irish unity and
independence
could only happen with the approval of
unionists secondly shin fein would be
able to attend a conference or set of
negotiations about the future
but only if the ira disavowed violence
and ended its campaign
and thirdly the republicans would have
to accept a redefinition of british
withdrawal
from northern ireland if the process was
to proceed now the traditional ira
view of british withdrawal was quite
literally a physical withdrawal the
troops would get on
on on the troop ships at belfast loch
the politicians and their civil servants
would troop out to walder grove airport
and
get on their shuttles and they would
disappear and
uh leaving everyone else remaining in
ireland unionists and nationalists
to sit down and hammer out the
settlement that was the traditional
ira republican view that would now have
to be discarded
and instead of the the british made a a
counter offer
and it was that they would withdraw but
only politically that is that they would
agree not to interfere
in any political talks not dictate
political talks
and would abide by their outcome and
would legislate for the outcome of these
talks
provided there was no violence and that
the principle of consent
was respected now at first glance that
seems to be an extraordinarily radical
uh statement by the british not least
because
the british to even mention the word
withdrawal was unheard of
in 1986 but it's actually less radical
than it might appear at first sight
because it had been an implicit and
explicit explicit principle of british
policy in northern ireland since 1972
when direct rule from london was imposed
and it was incorporated in the
1974 sunningdale power sharing agreement
and also the 1985.
uh anglo wires agreement it was not that
significant what did make it significant
was that here for the first time senior
republicans in the shape of jerry adams
and those around him
were prepared to accept a settlement
which had those characteristics
now if you look at those three elements
three main elements
in that document and look at what
actually did happen with the good friday
agreement it's there
almost word for word that's exactly what
did happen
shin fein has accepted the principle of
consent implicitly
they haven't signed a piece of paper
saying we accept the principle of
consent but they have
in practice done so they're rather like
soccer players
uh who disagree violently with the
offside rule but nevertheless agreed to
play in the cup final and if they win
they will take the cup home
so they have they have accepted it in
that sense secondly
they did attend the conference the good
friday negotiations was the conference
and the ira did disavow violence or at
least end its campaign
and thirdly uh this redefinition of
british withdrawal was incorporated
in the british government's uh uh
decision
uh to repeal the government of ireland
act 1920
which specifically said that the british
parliament
uh overrode the wishes of the people of
northern ireland that
it was another way of saying that they
had the right to interfere
in any settlement so they withdrew that
so all those things happened
and the document was there in 1986
my book argues that adam's accepted
these terms did so really only in his
own name as i said earlier this was a
highly secret uh process that he was
conducting and
the bulk of the ira particularly is army
leadership was unaware of what was going
on
um the british and of course also the
irish government later on thought he was
acting with the approval and authority
of the army council and it's doubtful
whether they would have conducted
discussions with him if they had thought
otherwise
but the truth was that he wasn't and
when the ira
intensified its violence in 1987 1988
for reasons which
i won't go into at this particular
moment in time the contrast between what
they were hearing
whispered in their ear by father reed as
the as being the uh view of jerry adams
the contrast between that and the
actuality on the ground where for
example tom king
uh was targeted by the ira his house in
somerset
was the subject of an ira surveillance
the guy went ballistic when he heard
this because he was
conducting private conversations uh
private correspondent very secret
correspondence with jerry adams and here
was the ira trying to kill him
uh so they they they thought the the
whole thing was
essentially a waste of time at that
point and
the the doubt that all this cast on
adams was bona fide is
very very nearly scuppered the whole
venture
it's difficult to know which of these
proposals that's the proposals in that
secret 1986 document
represented the biggest concession on
the part of the adams leadership but for
my money there's no doubt that it was
the acceptance of the principle of
consent that was the most important
opposition to this principle was a
defining belief for the ira
it's raison d'etre and to reject it was
to reject all the ira's methods and
beliefs and also the entire
war that they had been fighting and how
it had in fact been for nothing
but as a signal that adams wanted to
join constitutional politics
as a signal to the british and
ultimately to the irish government
it could not be equaled so by the late
1980s the peace process had got a route
map
and it had gone had some sort of
ideological basis
but the problem was that while jerry
adams and his allies were ready
for it the rest of the ira leadership
and the ira rank and file certainly were
not
and that's why i argue in the book that
much of the peace process was really
about
management management particularly of
the ira and sinn fein
support base as much as anything else
the existence of this secret document
and a parallel approach in 1987 to the
irish government under charles hockey
offering a ceasefire
and again acceptance of the consent
principle in return for an alliance a
political alliance
uh meant that everything that has
happened or everything that happened
after this period particularly in
relation to ira military strategy
has to be reassessed and reviewed in the
light of this knowledge of what was
going on secretly
others had to be managed in this process
for sure both the british
and the irish governments had to be
persuaded that adams was genuine
in the case of the british that took a
very long time
and possibly has not happened or did not
happen until tony blair became
prime minister and for a long time after
the
attempt to kill tom king there were
really three
sets of opinions in the british
establishment about what adams was up to
there was a
view on the part of this uh foreign
service on the foreign office
led by the secret service mi6 that adams
was genuine
they had of course the benefit of many
years of contact and conversation with
the ira leadership
a lot of it very secret others um
particularly the domestic
spying agency the equivalent if you like
of the fbi in britain known as mi5
believed it was just uh ira trickery
another case of uh
of the same old story uh in in different
clothing
and they argued against it and inside
the northern ireland office where
there was day-to-day responsibility uh
for
running northern ireland i think there
was a mixture of all of these views
and it depended who was the civil
servant and who was the prime minister
who was the minister
or secretary of state as to which one
was in the ascendancy so the british
were confused
and the irish took some time as well to
be completely persuaded that adams was
genuine
they were difficult to manage that's for
sure but the ira was even more difficult
to manage
they were still irredentous they were
still committed to the principle
the holy principle almost in their view
of armed struggle
but this i would argue and do argue in
the book was successfully accomplished
in two ways
the first was that the ira had to be
made to understand that military methods
were unlikely to succeed
and that it was time to give politics a
chance and there's no doubt in my mind
that the most
and the single most effective leader in
this regard the point at which i would
argue
that the ira's war really came to an end
was the discovery as a result of
betrayal
in 1987 of the excellent the ship
excellent and it's 150 tons of guns and
explosives
most of it modern weaponry supplied by
libya's colonel gaddafi
the exons was the last of five shipments
and was to be the cutting edge
in the ira's version of the tet
defensive a series of attacks on such a
scale in northern ireland
in britain and on the european continent
that they were intended
no matter how unsuccessful they were in
achieving their military targets
they were intended like the impact of
the vietnamese version in 1968 on us
opinion
to sicken british public opinion and to
create a demand for a radical new policy
in ireland
on ireland but with the excellence
capture
the ira lost its valuable cargo and more
importantly the element of surprise
and it was back militarily speaking to
the drawing board for the ira
and i would argue that at this point the
peace process a political alternative
becomes the only viable option that the
ira leadership can follow
the question of um excuse me question of
who betrayed the excellent
and that it was betrayed there is no
doubt whether it was someone on board
the vessel
which is entirely possible whether it
was good intelligence work by the irish
british or american authorities who
worked very closely on these matters
whether it was loose talk by the ira and
they are notorious for gossiping amongst
themselves about what's going on
or whether it was some senior ira
figures came to believe
the act of a traitor at the highest
level of the ira perhaps someone
who was privy to what was going on on
the army council because all this was
all this uh activity about the accident
was kept a closely guarded secret in
theory at least from the rest of the ira
is a question from these troubles that i
would argue ranks alongside
the great puzzle from the 1919 1921
conflict or its aftermath at least
and that is who killed michael collins
and why
whether there was an actual trader
somewhere at the top of the ira
is less important than the fact that a
lot of people in the ira believed and
still believe
that there was one and every single
reversal suffered by the ira during this
period
from the massacre of the east tyrone
brigade in 87 through to the killings in
gibraltar
and beyond is replete with ira
suspicions that a high-level trader was
responsible
of all the assertions in this book the
allegation that
people in the ira suspected that there
was an informer uh
is possibly uh the the most
controversial
i do not know nor do i say that there
was a deliberate policy by the adams
leadership to sabotage the armed
struggle
the evidence either way is just not
strong enough at this stage
but this much is evident and undeniable
when adams approached the british in
1986
he gave the british government a
priceless insight into his mind and his
intentions
he was essentially telling them that he
would accept less than the ira's
stated war aims and as a piece of
intelligence
which the british could use to shape
their military and their political
strategy in the years afterwards
that was priceless and this is not of
course the first time that this has
happened in irish history as paul bu
pointed out in his review of my book
exactly the same thing happened during
michael collins period
the british knew that michael collins
was prepared to do a deal that was less
than
the deal which the ira stated was its
objective
and they set out to strengthen collins
friends and and to weaken
his enemies and so i would argue was it
just coincidence
that uh the ira that the british turned
the full force
of their uh counter-terrorist campaign
against the ira
in toronto during this period knowing
full well
that from tyrone you were going to get
the strongest
opposition to the adam strategy was it
just a coincidence i i don't know
but this much i can say even right up
until the 1996 ira convention
by which time the ira in in tyrone had
been decimated it was just a shadow of
what it used to be
the strongest and most anti-peace
process motion
put before the ira rank and file at that
secret meeting came from east terron
imagine what it had been like
had for example the hard men who were
involved in the east in the local
massacre if they had survived was it
just coincidence that
in 1988 margaret thatcher decided to
pour millions and millions and millions
of pounds
into intelligence gathering operations
in northern ireland
i don't know but these are questions
that are there a lot of people find them
unpalatable but they are there and they
are valid questions
the ira's campaign was shaped in other
ways
as the peace process picked up speed the
inevitable botched operations those
which went wrong and cost civilian
civilian lives
were highlighted by figures like jerry
adams as obstacles in the way of
schindefein's electoral growth
now botched operations had always been
characteristic of the ira and some of
the worst ones have entered
the annals of infamy and i i remember
one
in particular that stands out and that
was bloody friday in belfast in
in july 1972 i was still a student there
and
living in in an apartment near the
university
the one of the very first bombs went off
at the end of the street
and within a space of two or three
minutes twenty more car bombs went off
in belfast and we climbed to the top of
the house which was a three-story
building
and looked over into the city center and
all you could see was the smoke
blowing towards you from these bombs
and the the cries and the screams
of of people trying to escape not
knowing which way to go
if they move this way would they go into
the path of an unexploded car bomb it
was an awful day
a lot of people died that day it wasn't
the only watched operation that the ira
uh was responsible for during that time
but in those days
they got away with it and they got away
with it because you could be pretty sure
that by the end of the week the british
had done their botched operation
they had done their their equivalent or
that the loyalists had done something
equally despicable and by
you know something happened on a monday
that was grotesque and horrible by the
sunday had been overtaken by events but
by the late 1980s and early 1990s the
british at least had learned their
lessons and they
they uh from all of this and they were
no longer
in the in the business of reprisals and
the ira's botched operations stood out
starkly uh as uh
as as condemnations of effectively the
armed struggle
but the problem with all of this as a
result of the
research that i've been able to to do is
that many of those operations which were
full of civilian risk excuse me
were approved by the ira leadership
by martin mcginnis for example who was
northern commander of the ira and
carried day-to-day responsibility for
the organization's campaign
there were many examples of this type of
operation the enerskill and poppy day
bomb was one
if you remember that one that was a bomb
which was planted at a building or put
in
secreted in a building beside the
cenotaph in the center of venezuelan the
theory behind it being that
when the british soldiers turned up
in uh dress uniform
to to participate in the ceremony the
november 11th armistice
ceremony this bomb would be detonated
and
they would be killed but of course what
actually did happen was that the place
was full of civilians as it always was
on november
11th and and it was the civilians who
were killed not the soldiers and anyone
who was doing their
basic intelligence work on an operation
like that would have known that
that was an operation which was um which
was uh
approved by by northern command not just
by magnus but
by the entire staff in 1990 the army
council which included adams not just
mcguinness also approved
the first use of so-called human bombs
long before 9 11
in which a civilian would be forced to
drive a car full of explosives to an
army or police checkpoint
where the ira other members of the ira
would be waiting with a radio detonating
device that pressed the button
and the poor soul who was driving the
car would be evaporated
uh killed killing not just the soldiers
but obviously him as well
in the pantheon of irish public
relations or ira public relations
disasters
the human bombs of which the derry one
was only one is a campaign which lasted
for several months
rate first in stupidity and crassness
yet their use was approved by people who
were complaining every day
that the ira took too many risks with
civilian lives
the lesson nevertheless from this and
other botched operations was a simple
one
we on the outside did not know what the
command structures were we did not know
who was approving the operations
we assumed i remember assuming and
writing
uninformed articles about uh you know
was the ira at a low level uh
rebelling against the leadership in some
way shape or form we did not know i did
not know at that stage that these were
operations which had been
approved at the very very highest level
of the ira
nevertheless uh the the message from all
of these botched operations was the same
one and that was that civilian deaths uh
civilian deaths which harmed chinfang's
political cause could could be avoided
and political damage to the cause only
by ending the armed struggle
altogether again that's another
unpalatable question because it raises
all sorts of very dark issues
but nevertheless it's a valid question
which i think historians in the future
will have to address
all this had a profound impact on the
ira strategy
and served to severely limit adoptions
its options
but with the exception of adams and
those privy to the to his enterprise
the ira leadership was still not by the
late 1980s involved
officially in a sanctioned peace process
the problem of how the ira's generals
the
people on the army council that i call
soldiers in the book those who were
never in the chin fame
were always army men decried sinn fein
only one
uh thing was for them and that was to
fight the war
the problem of how these people could be
cajoled down the path that jerry adams
clearly wanted to go and which had been
outlined
by both the british and subsequently by
the irish government
was solved in 1988 when the army council
made two
very important decisions both on the
urging of jerry adams and his allies
one was to adopt the strategy of
so-called pan nationalism that is the
creation of an alliance
of of nationalists in ireland
republicans
the irish government and john humes sdlp
and of course
later and subsequently irish america
expanded eventually
to include the clinton white house and
the idea behind this
uh alliance was that together it could
exert pressure on the british
in a way which perhaps the iras campaign
could not and the ira leadership saw
a good deal of sense in that the second
and related decision was to make
an important change in ira policy
relating to british withdrawal
the early hardline policy of the
provisional ira was to demand the
british
should withdraw from the north within
the lifetime of the parliament the
british parliament that is that's about
four or five years
and the reason for that was that they
didn't trust the brits they thought if
they gave the brits any longer than that
then
uh the the ira would in the intervening
years get uh weaker
because the war was over and then the
british would eventually renege
and of course the very bad memories
within the
culture of irish republicanism of what
happened to long ceasefires
in the 1920s uh there are those who
believe that
the real reason why the uh
negotiations the anglo-irish
negotiations of 1920 1921 did not
succeed in getting the republic was that
the ceasefire lasted too long the ira
relaxed its guard
and it revealed itself to its enemy
nevertheless despite those fears in in
1988 the army council changed its policy
on
british withdrawal and agreed that from
now on withdrawal could take 20 years
or even longer to happen maybe 30 years
but they added an important caveat
notwithstanding the new flexibility the
british still had to name
a definite date for their final
departure and so by 1988 89
and certainly by 1990 the official ira
strategy
was to construct a widespread
nationalist alliance involving
constitutional nationalists the irish
government
the sinn fein irish america which would
press for a declaration of intent by the
british
to leave northern ireland in say the
year 2020 or perhaps even later 2030
2040 and
in the meantime negotiations would open
about the sort of arrangements
which would suit and which would be
needed to accommodate uh
unionism and so negotiations began with
the irish government
with john hume as the intermediary this
is where hume comes into his own in the
peace process
on a statement or declaration that the
two governments would make about their
future policy and intentions on northern
ireland
the negotiations eventually stalled as
they were always going to stall
over the issue of a date for british
withdrawal because if they had inserted
a clause which said we are going to
withdraw by 2020
effectively it would be ignoring and
overruling the principle of consent
because it was saying no matter what the
unionists believe or think we're still
going by this date
so the negotiations stalled over that
issue neither the major government john
major government in london nor the
reynolds government in dublin would
countenance this
it flew in the face of established
british and irish policy
since the very early 1970s
excuse me so they went ahead and they
negotiated their own statement which we
know is the downing street declaration
which was published
in the christmas of 1993 through which
the consent principle ran like a
silken thread the principles inherent in
the declaration were exactly the same
principles
as those contained in the secret message
to jerry adams
way back in 1986 so you had two parallel
universes if you like here you had
the official ira strategy which was
pan-nationalism
and a date for withdrawal then you had
what i would argue with the real peace
process to which adams and a few other
people in the republican movement
and the governments are really privy
which is effectively about accepting the
principle of consent
the army councils hard men the soldiers
on the army council were in a fix
they had been maneuvered to a
negotiating process from which there was
no escape
to reject the downstream declaration
publicly would be to risk certain
condemnation
and further isolation and weakness to
accept it publicly
would risk a split in their ranks so
they sat on their hands and they played
for time
time was of course against the army
council and on the side of those like
adams who favored a ceasefire
as public and international pressure
grew for a ceasefire
adams was able in 1994 to persuade the
council
to go for an experimental four-month
cessation which of course in practice
lasted much longer as it was always
intended to
there were many difficulties ahead that
ceasefire broke down in 1996
over the refusal of a again a
distrustful british government who
engaged adams in in in negotiations
and the rest of the process would take
years to complete it wasn't until 1998
that the good friday agreement was was
finally uh
agreed it wasn't until the year 2001 ira
decommissioning
happened it may not be until the year
2003 that the ira begins to disband
but essentially the dye had been cast at
this point
and the ira leadership had been
maneuvered very cleverly very skillfully
into a course of action which would lead
to all of these things
they were if you like pushed down the
neck of a bottle
and although they clung grimly to the
side eventually
they lost their hand hold and they
slipped down to the bottom
it was i argue in this book the work of
a strategic genius
a ruthless and for some people an
unattractive genius for sure
but nevertheless a genius and in
completing his 20-year journey away from
violence i think jerry adams has assured
himself a place alongside collins and de
valera
as one of ireland's major revolutionary
and wily political figures
the journey he has completed is very
similar he's embraced constitutionalism
in the same way as they did but it was
also a much more difficult and dangerous
journey
the provisional iras war was longer
dirtier more brutal bloodier more
intractable
more sectarian than anything collins or
devalera had to cope with
and for that reason it's the equivalent
as one ecumenical cleric told me during
my research for the book
to adam's turning the titanic in a
bathtub
it was an achievement of that sort of
measure and
what i think we can say from all over
this is that no matter what happens now
politically whether i'm right and the
good friday agreement is rescued or
whether the pessimists
are right and the thing collapses one
thing is for sure
one thing is unalterably uh changed
the ira's war with britain is finally
over
thank you very much
thank you